I'm Java Drake and I am a lecturer and
visiting scholar and my sort of plan of
Engagement has really been to deepen the
collaboration and co-inventorship and
coaching of students that I've been
doing in the in the battery and energy
space
created lab exercises which would give
them hands-on experience with
cholesterol chemical cells they partner
in teams of two or three
and her sort of an objective to charge
up or refuel a cell which is it's
similar to a battery and then operate
and see how long they can operate it for
it's really about reminding students
that some of the things they may be
learning they're very abstract bringing
it to a hey this is a real application
where this is useful
I come from industry so I've had over 20
plus years in industry it's a big a big
transition for me and I would say the
m1k scholar program is uh is is really
important in helping me make this
transition
it's really about enabling the batteries
and we've been working on Lithium-ion
batteries it's been our collaboration
enabling them to last dramatically
longer and enabling them to charge very
rapidly
the way that MLK did things were by
drawing people through his passion and
his his vision for things I'm sort of
expressing my passion and trying to draw
the students who may be interested
I'm very passion driven type of
scientist engineer that's maybe one one
way of framing it yeah
foreign